too all right guys
who's here
yeah it's a it's um alive oh we're live
yeah i just went live
there's no one on it yet i just thought
mommy's in the club should i put it on
so i'm gonna put it on
it's okay
if we get coffee
we won't oh i don't care it's alive so i
don't it's oh i see how that was funny
come on turn it up my speakers are
broken
so awkward we're live i'm sending it
tony
your camera quality is fire oh my god
are people watching before you can see
right there
and then you do like a live chat
oh hello
you never do it on your phone
oh i always just whip out my phone like
randomly and go live like i'll go live
with my mom you know what i'm gonna take
your branch
and this is gonna hold this
oh yeah much better
i didn't bring any makeup back from the
uk
i don't need it
no um
one actually as a ginger i feel like
makeup is the most beneficial for ginger
i'm just very lazy tell me shouldn't i
just send you the
[Music]
i should have brought my i have like
in the most respectful way possible
your boobs are like bigger in person
it's my man's singing or
[Laughter]
okay where is this was gonna be the one
okay
i'm thinking the jack that will work oh
i should have brought my thing hold it
i'm in here
i'm just gonna do it before we go live
no i'm back from the uk
and
we're from the same area we live 45
minutes away and people like asking
questions it's too bad you weren't here
last year i had no friends
i live in my parents house for a year
i'm putting it in our tasks toni
oh wait no i can't enough yeah
donovan's
did you get it
um
my uk phone one's my u.s phone
one time
my ex-boyfriend um
was very we got into a big fight and
then to make me not mad he bought me a
phone
the other time
we got into a fight he took me to the
nba finals so you can't
you know what i said what i said one
time me and my ex-boyfriend got to a
fight so he bought me a phone and then i
was like another time
oh no
fine okay that way i was gonna i could
switch it
i could switch it
like let me put that there instead okay
okay
thank you
and then i was like
another time another time you got into a
fight but you have to tell them to
follow me so they can watch oh yeah guys
guys we're going live on torsha's
channel
what is it t-o-r-s-h-a-a that's your
channel i'm trying to talk about
guys follow me on my youtube channel
t-o-r-s-h-a-a
yeah
we're gonna go a lot what time are we
going live
eight minutes eight thirty eight there's
a countdown on my channel you mean
eighteen he said seven no and look at
the thing eighteen minutes oh eighteen
minutes
okay yeah
are you nervous i'm gonna grill you
you're gonna grill me
what is this ridiculous top
[ __ ] you what yours
is
wait look at this
so you can vouch for me
oh he's talking about mine now the blue
sweater for the gym
guys i spent most of my life in the gym
like literally i have a proper 12 shirt
that i kind of want to wear but
it's fine that's mcgregor's uh whiskey
yeah yeah you love him
um oh my gosh do you
have
do you want to put the link to your live
in this chat yeah so she's i got a crown
now i'm talking about the blue top
what's wrong with my blue top it's it's
brand name i like who's talking [ __ ]
small dick energy hear me out hear me
out it matches my shoes
oh no they're not white those are cool
shoes it'll show up white oh yeah okay
yeah look at look at champion in matches
sorry for matching just like my dad
sir
oh my god the other day someone made a
hate video on me it was so funny they
said i was um
jezebel spirit
yeah it was sad it was like it's like um
someone in the bible it was so funny oh
like the devil yeah yeah i just spit i
showed my whole family i thought it was
so funny
no it was kind of if anybody's that i
think it's me the jezebel spirit i mean
my boobs are out there
oh no it was because your mom watch your
videos
no sometimes she watches my tick tocks
more hi mom
um
sorry
no the where am i going just pearly
things i was like is your real name
probably remember that
oh it's my middle name
i know yeah hannah yeah yeah but i
prefer pearl most people call me pearl
outside of my family
um
um
where the hell am i going wait is
donovan's real name
not donovan
i saw that online
it's donven it's whatever he bought
everybody has a pseudo name i think
really yeah okay i didn't know that
i guess i kind of do it's my middle name
yeah youtube
i guess i didn't need to do that i don't
know why i made it more everybody has a
suitable oh this is weird
i'm almost there
you just have to turn off the volume i
know sorry i didn't even notice
um
i feel like i what are
obvious troll dude crying right now here
if you guys want me to put on a
turtleneck i'll do it and then we can
roast the guy that ruined it for
everybody
that's fine with me
no i'm kidding we do not like bullying
and we do not
enjoy
doxing do you cut hair
my mom used to why oh i need a haircut i
got you yes should i go grab scissors
you got some i do you know how to like
actually kind of
yeah i need the dead end i'm like jack
of all trades
i don't know why i was like i bet she
knows how to cut
i don't know why that came to my mind
actually i tried to cut side swept bangs
and shelly got so mad shout out i just
all i want is my dead ends gone which is
a lot they have a tool for that where
you just put your hair in and
it doesn't look promising it looks
terrifying but really it's like one it's
like putting your hand in a slicer and
hoping for the best
i had a friend in college that i'd
always like cut my hair i'd give her
like five bucks
all right sorry are you
happy with your that
shot that angle
can you see
this one yeah i'm not going to be
looking at her though if i'm like here i
don't like that side of my face so i'm
not going to look at you
yeah right
yeah because i want my microphone i
guess i could
this is where i would normally
go but she would be there it's okay
i guess it doesn't matter right
tell me
you don't you don't want to look at her
i mean i probably should but i could
look at her through the lines
i'm sorry
tell me
your vein without telling me your vein
that was wow that wasn't fun
but you're good with that why did yeah
that's fine why did barbie never get
pregnant why because she's a doll
because you can came in another box
that's a good one right
why would the fish run into the wall
wait no no what did he say when he ran
into the wall damn
you know
yeah
okay
let's see
you're gonna need a babysitter
how why do i look so washed out in this
one but in there i look like homies
still my night oh my god
wow i didn't get anyone how much was
that camera
i it's like seven
i think they dropped the price too and
it's a good one but the battery life is
so bad
horrible you have to keep it plugged in
it dies when you turn it on really it's
horrible i don't know why they market it
as a vlogging camera i mean i haven't
plugged it but right but how do you vlog
with it plugged in i'm gonna have to
bring my laptop in like a tray and just
like go like this like it doesn't make
sense dude
the
fudge
i look so hot on that camera
i'm like checking myself out
i look hot on the phone
decent
this this mic is good and it was what a
hundred bucks
20. this one this one was like 20. yeah
really with the stand and everything
how much was that one
that's like 400 400
i wonder if i should have her
tony do you think i we can put her mic
there
put it there yeah why
because should i not talk to her like i
don't know is that weird is it gonna
look weird no we're switching right
we're doing live switching yeah so it
doesn't matter i just have to like look
you should kind of be looking that way i
can't do it not on that side of my face
why your face doesn't even look
different on each side yeah it does let
me see let me see we are alive
move this okay more like this
thank you
my mouth is like paralyzed on one side
literally
you don't need a babysitter call a
babysitter
isn't it catching it's a banger you want
to hear it when it's sped up 1.25
yeah let's hear it all right hold on
i
love doing this [ __ ]
okay
i was like was it 1.5 maybe
really fast
wait let me go to his that was somebody
else's
life
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
i don't know who he was talking about
but one of us looks boring
to be around
or like looks good but it's boring to be
around
all right banana spirit i was
like oh my god
[Music]
let us know in the chat what we should
talk about today
you got it yeah okay
in the fridge yeah i wonder what it is
you all need a babysitter
this video have too much info everyone
wants to know where we live that we can
afford a house this
big well
again
not me my parents but um it's not texas
it's not middle of nowhere we actually
live in the chicago suburbs everyone i
think that was bad how are they gonna
find me
no one knows where we are except i
accidentally put torsha on google
uh
map
like here
or in the area wait let me see the slide
there you go oh thank you
this is so funny like selena powell
oh shut the [ __ ] up dude
trash trash my father raised me better
better than that
she was the one on f that data dj
academics
you do what's up pearl how are you doing
today i'm like like be sweet i love
incels just be nice
where is
there
or who am i looking for okay
oh he sent me something
i wanted to go see that we were popping
okay guys um i'm gonna end this live
okay keep it on if you want but no
um but go to torsh's channel
and well shut up
and the link is in the chat so you can
do it again but my phone's gonna die
okay